et je m'appelle goody et en 1841 j'ai
été mordu par un vampire si j'y arrive à
se tester
je vivais pas la nuit je prenais
énormément dexter regardez clignote
qu'est-ce que tu ferais tu trouves pas
ça bizarre qu'une moitié de thé cannes
ils soient propres alors que l'autre
c'est la tournée des boîtes avec tous
ces mecs lourds dingues qui nous drague
sur la voiture trop rester jeune on
devient vieux bonne journée
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un en cours il est
maladroit mais il est trop mignon
comment il s'appelle il s'appelle joy
bond est le signe pardon qu'est-ce que
ses parents de penser de moi on la
trouve exagérément blanche vous ne
l'aimez pas à cause de la couleur de sa
tête un zombie nom de dieu je crois que
tous les gens sont des vampires
quelles sont vos intentions ce qui
concerne mon fils je voulais vous dire
vous prévoyez de le vider de son énergie
répondez moi pas plus qu'une autre
petite amie il se passe des choses
vraiment étrange en ce moment on essaie
de nous forcer à voir le soleil de
techniciens du câble sort de chez lui
tellement humble n'irai pas jusqu'à
buter les gens chez eux quand même ils
sont terribles notre communauté de plus
en plus persécutée appellera les gros
gagnants
nous allons devoir resserrer les rangs
ça vous dirait de devenir les femmes
comptent sur moi c'est et roddick
votre femme et elle est sûr c'est que
mon comptable vous dis que je suis
expert comptable j'ai eu comme
l'impression d'être sur une autre
planète